como diz gilberto gil sobre a baía lhe
ter o régua e compasso minha mãe e toda
a minha vivência caiçara aqui também me
deram régua e compasso para a minha vida
é um pouco sobre isso que eu quero falar
aqui hoje como a uma vivência ter
nascido né aqui nesse paraíso foi
importante pra mim como isso me levou é
é até aqui enfim hoje me chamam pra
fazer parte dessa coisa linda na cidade
onde eu nasci isso é muito emocionante e
isso é muito importante realmente quando
eu cheguei em são paulo eu tinha só 16
anos eu tinha um objetivo muito claro eu
ia ser professora de história e voltar
rapidamente pra cá e passar boa parte da
vida e trabalhando meio período como
professora e outro meio período eu ia
fazer o que eu fazia sempre que era
maravilhoso andar de bicicleta mergulhar
veleja pegar onda e praia catar síria e
catar brigam começo viver disso
rapidamente isso se mostrou impossível
porque eu entrei na faculdade de
jornalismo também e já no primeiro ano
eu fui abduzida pelo rádio e já comecei
a atender telefone numa rádio chamada à
cultura à m
eu atendia telefone por um cara chamado
walter silva se vocês não conhecem o
pica-pau cara que fez grande os
programas de rádio fez também alguns
shows incríveis como os shows de elis
regina no teatro para amanhã em são
paulo
eu tinha só 18 anos eu tenho 50 agora
então eu tenho 32 anos the radio tom
absolutamente viciada nisso não estaria
nisso até hoje porque eu não consigo
entender uma vida é de trabalho uma vida
que não dê prazer que não dê alegria que
não dê felicidade isso foi uma coisa que
eu aprendi também em casa com a minha
mãe quando eu entrei na rádio cultura e
deparei com um 50 mil lps pra ouvir a
tarde inteira que era mais ou menos o
que eu fazia no começo eu descobri que
ela cantava como eu sou a filha da
chiquita bacana o chiquita bacana da
martinica no evento
são dela era clássico né eram clássicos
do samba brasileiro
e aí eu fui descobrindo a minha relação
é é íntima com o rádio e com a música
que já existia e eu nem sabia como diz
lenny são arquivos ocultos que vai
abrindo no decorrer da sua vida e aquilo
vai te confirmando o caminho e eu estava
lá com 18 19 20 e 21 anos 22 e 23
era uma diretora de programas de rádio e
tv com 23 anos e engravidei da minha
filha era casada com o pai dela nessa
época tive a gabriela uma menina linda
hoje com 26 anos
só que quando ela tava pra fazer um ano
eu me separei do pai dela ea minha vida
meio que desmoronou e ficou aquela coisa
e agora o que eu faço pra onde vou com a
família pequena que em são paulo não tem
praia não tem mar
vou pra casa e aí eu estava em são paulo
junto com meu irmão gustavo que mora em
maresias a surfista somos cinco caixas
farinhas na espalhados por aqui só eu lá
e ele assistindo tv junto comigo a gente
ali eu ele gabriela que era uma pipoca
sem pequenininha já estava ali
assistindo já custou com aquele bandido
da praia que ele aquela vontade de estar
aqui de alguma maneira de fazer alguma
coisa mais presos nele fazendo faculdade
de jornalismo eu já é com o trabalho
ganhando dinheiro e tá mais infeliz
massa já custou na tela ea gente começa
a pulsar como seria maravilhoso se eu já
custou o tá na equipe do já custou a
gente ainda criança eu tinha 23 24 anos
ele e aí a gente começou a pensar pô mas
televisão dá pra fazer é caro para
caramba viajar o mundo inteiro difícil
né mas depois rádio eu sei fazer então
por que não faz um programa de rádio com
essa cara do já custou o bahia então um
programa que falasse de de sanfins de
meio ambiente de vela de mergulho tá mas
como seria o nome deste programa passa
uma baleia azul pela tela a gente vira
baleia azul e é claro
e aí eu vim pra são sebastião e trouxe a
proposta para a rádio beiramar de fazer
um programa de música e meio ambiente em
1991 a mulher olhou na minha cara e
falou está completamente louca isso
existe imagina música e meio ambiente
quer meio ambiente que está a falar de
baleia aqui sim
a baleia e o meu já estava tudo pronto
para a abertura era o canto da baleia
jubarte misturado com reg do alpha
blondy perfeito mesmo falar como é que
ela não quer um negócio desse
ela queria ela é incrível aí ela falou o
seguinte eu preciso um programa de
música sertaneja eu faço não tem
problema mas desde que você me deu
espaço beleza e aí eu fiz um manhã
sertaneja pra ela era um programa que é
pro ar se não me engano a cinco da manhã
até às 8 e falava de defeso lua o que
podia pescar naquela hora o que não sei
o quê porque era para o sertanejo que
morava na praia e tocava obviamente o
que estava bombando na época era estamos
em choró em roberta miranda e terá eu
tive uma grande ajuda de uma amiga minha
infância aqui a débora laura que palavra
no meu lugar de manhãzinha e eu mandava
aquela programação inteira para rádio e
ganhei na sexta feira às 9 da noite o
baleia azul
o pessoal tem a minha idade é que deve
lembrar do balé zhu
era um programa muito divertido era
sexta feira às 9 da noite era isso aí a
alpha blondy era regra era itamar
assumpção hora gilberto gil era música
do brasil e do mundo e eu fazia as
reportagens de meio ambiente com uma
fita cassete um gravador cassete que
acreditava em casa soltava no microfone
o barulho do cometidos atobás fragatas a
gente ia pra alcatrazes a gente andava
no mato e levava tudo aquilo pra lá e
ainda carregava os lps para entrar no ar
em 1992 na rio-92 com a ajuda do zé
antônio ou pedro taque fotografando a
gente fez uma transmissão ao vivo do rio
de janeiro eu de lá no orelhão e ele nas
picapes e recebem aqui em são sebastião
ea gente tentou levar pra o jornal local
essa cobertura que me disse que como era
no rio de janeiro a gente aqui não tinha
nada a ver com isso
não sei se imagina o que foi ficar no ar
aqui cinco anos com um programa de
música e meio ambiente naquele momento
em que não se falava sobre isso
o programa foi bacana mas a gente
aprendeu bem naquele momento em que
você tem um rumo na sua vida mas que é
importante você e corrigindo as rotas
para você chegar em algum lugar e isso
você vai fazendo é meio intuitivamente
meio sem querer e meio porque uma rajada
entra te leva para lá outra teve o barco
noroeste quebra o mastro
mas a gente vai corrigindo e vai sempre
uma coisa na cabeça eu me lembro que eu
cheguei em são paulo com 16 anos e sete
por aí eu ouvir de alguém que eu era uma
casará lutando contra o meu destino
lá em são paulo e aquilo me intrigava
muito não tinha muita ferramenta não
tinha muito que dizer contra aquilo
porque também nunca fui de lutar contra
nada eu sou de jogar junto
aí eu tava pensando cara caiçara tem um
estilo só é o meu destino porque eu sou
caiçara na verdade isso fosse isso foi
mimi percorrendo até hoje eu ainda penso
nessa frase e penso como a gente pode
ser capaz de tomar o destino da gente na
nossa mão né
como as escolhas na verdade é que
definem e não o lugar onde você nasceu
oak etnia você pertence que como você
tem que sexo você prefere
tanto faz o importante é você tem na sua
cabeça que você precisa colaborar ser
feliz
mas uma coisa que eu aprendi com minha
mãe e isso ficava na minha cabeça eu
sempre querendo incomodada transformar
as coisas transformar a minha vida e
isso foi mas eu sou uma caixa lutando
contra o meu destino
não compreendo nem mas sigamos em frente
está incomodando deixar ali do ladinho
depois a gente arruma e vamos indo
porque tem coisa para fazer e tem coisa
para fazer e tem coisa para fazer
aí voltei para são paulo com quase 30
anos porque o dinheiro aqui acabou né
não dava imaginem eu entendo nada mais
ou menos do que estava fazendo o que
todo mundo tava entendendo mas eu não
tinha como é fazer isso virá naquele
momento para que isso fosse a minha vida
me sustentar se a mim ea minha filha com
aquela ideologia a gente teve um
programa de rádio um jornalzinho
almanaque que viveu uma ou duas edições
um grupo de vivência ambiental que
também viveu pouco uma lojinha um
entreposto ecológico baleia azul que
também viveu um pouco mais o
ando a gente transformou atletas baleia
azul eram patrocinados ganhando a
camiseta e faziam os seus campeonatos de
sanfins levando o nosso nome adiante a
gente ia nos campeonatos de pra dizer
olha é preciso preservar para continuar
curtindo se você jogar plástico na praia
da tartaruga essa onda que se conhecem
bem
ok acabou o dinheiro foi embora para são
paulo comecei em são paulo a trabalhar
na rádio eldorado onde eu fiz um grande
caminho assim eu comecei como repórter
especial de meio ambiente e logo estava
no ar fazendo programas ao vivo e ali
também eu tomei um outro tombo e esse
tombo me deu um presente na vida que foi
o vozes do brasil que é o programa de
rádio que eu faço até hoje em oito
emissoras pelo país afora está há 18
anos no ar um programa sobre música
brasileira especialmente e ele já rendeu
dois livros e ele continua numa linda
linda caminhada por aí mas foi outro
tombo né acaba o dinheiro servirá de
novo ah isso é demitida do lugar servirá
de novo mas sem nunca achar que o lugar
ali embaixo a dificuldade é o permanente
porque não tem permanente na vida como
não tem mar igual todo dia então eu hoje
eu vi aqui muita gente falando dessa
experiência de ir para o mar se
descobriu vilmar enfim é tão importante
você está do lado da natureza perceber a
natureza quanto é importante perceber a
sua própria natureza e você parte de
tudo isso
ninguém aqui está isolado dinho ninguém
aqui jst essa tribo maravilhosa que nós
temos tanta gente que amo mariama
natureza que está vindo pra cá de novo
eu vim pra cá nos anos 90 eu nasci aqui
claro
aí voltei nos anos 90 foi complicado foi
difícil mas tem muita gente que está
aqui até hoje e isso está acontecendo é
fruto da quele momento nos anos 90 em
que a gente chegou aqui e nós somos
fruto dessas mulheres maravilhosas como
dona priscila siqueira com minha mãe e
tantas outras que aqui vivem e que tão
todo o tempo é alimentando a gente dessa
energia transformadora que não deixa a
gente ficar sentadinho no conforto como
disse luciano recatadas e do lar né
imagina a gente vai para o mar a gente
atravessa os oceanos a gente surfa faz
programa de rádio mil coisas então tá
aqui hoje com vocês é absolutamente
inspirador para mim ouvir essas pessoas
todas é absolutamente inspirador e
aquela coisa toda aqui eu ouvia se é uma
caixa lutando contra o seu destino
porque senão estudo em boas escolas você
não tem uma família conhecida aqui em
são paulo onde é que você vai trabalhar
pra mim é tão careta é tão bobo é tão
preconceituoso é tão burro né que é como
você dizer sei lá não sei nem o que
dizer a respeito porque eles não faz
parte do meu vocabulário não faz parte
do meu repertório eu digo que é uma
menina para uma criança pra minha filha
você é tudo o que você quiser
não importa né kaissara sorte sua
tive sorte de nascer aqui e eu agradeço
todos os dias da minha vida por ser
caiçara
agradeço todos os dias da minha vida por
ter vivido o noroeste aí no meio do
canal aprender a se virar meu barquinho
agradeço todos os dias da minha vida a
minha mãe meu pai os meus avós a minha
filha e agradeço mais que tudo a são
sebastião que me deu régua e compasso
então quando eu lembro dessa frase você
é uma caçarola lutando contra o seu
destino eu lembro por cá eu acabei de
criar uma rádio digital 24 horas no ar
um monte de gente trabalhando junto
comigo e ela cabe o aqui
veja que coisa louca
o destino está na minha mão é muito
importante isso é agente desencanada
essas frases horrorosas que você ouve ou
melhor você ouve e transformar isso num
motor para sua vida não quis te de ruby
mas que este leve para frente então
muito obrigada pela oportunidade
esse é um tributo ao cantor